you know I was thinking about wearing a
hoodie but I wasn't looking here Lee's
good in it Luke Cage all right I'm
getting this out
a few days after most people who tend to
do these sorts of things because I don't
have the time or the energy to binge it
through in two or three days but I have
seen the entirety of the series of Luke
Cage and I did it quickly enough that I
think I'm still worth talking about it
so what did I think it's pretty good I
mean for for my part there are things
that just didn't quite work for me some
of which I can chalk up to personal
taste some of which I think are actually
kind of issue so I let me be upfront
about the fact that this was one of
those things where I can watch it and I
can appreciate what is good and what
works about it and at the same time
recognize that while it's not completely
connecting to me that's probably because
I'm not completely lining up with the
ideal audience for this thing I mean I
don't mean to make this a race thing I
don't need to make this a white/black
thing but as a point of comparison I
think of when I saw something like
Straight Outta Compton which was a very
good movie and I'm glad I saw it I would
never go back and watch it again I
didn't overly connect with it but it's
because that's never really been my
world and I don't just mean the black
experience I mean I'm not really into
hip-hop either but I can still recognize
that it was a good movie and see the
strengths in it while still not really
latching onto it on personal level and
simply recognize that that's not any
fault of the movie or in this case the
TV show and I feel there's a certain
amount of that going on here as well but
I like to start positive so let's talk
about what works well Cage worked he
works before when we saw him and Jessica
Jones he works here he's still good I
mean he looks stellar he just looks so
good just standing he's just so big and
muscular and he's taking the hits just
but you know even when he has to engage
and actually talk to people and he's got
this wonderful
Cornie rapport with so many of the
characters and it's even gets pointed
out to usually by rosario Dawson how
corny and cheesy is so that they kind of
hung a lampshade on it I like that I
liked it I liked his whole deal I liked
his body was good most of the supporting
cast is really good pop was good for the
brief period he was around oh I guess
I'll mention spoilers I'm not going to
consider it a big spoiler that pop guys
who did not call that pop was gonna die
but from here on out we'll say spoilers
you got my general overview so going
from that you know we got the return of
rosario dawson she's always been good on
if beyond the fact that they seem to be
pointing towards kind of a romantic
angle between her and Luke but I'm iffy
on that almost any time it happens
regardless of who doesn't as far as the
two of them you know what it's not too
bad I really liked misty night I liked I
liked how human she was that she was a
badass and a good detective but at the
same time she's vulnerable and she is
subject to the stress and you see him
wearing on her at certain points in
certain just mistakes that she makes
just dinner in her police work because
she's so frustrated with this system and
everything that is not doing likes
cottonmouth a whole lot he was
charismatic as heck I really liked
Mariah Dillard she was fantastic I'm
really one of the highlights of the show
as a whole for me and did in terms of
her progression and the performance in
general she was great
I actually surprisingly really liked
shades and I don't say surprisingly like
I expected the character to be crap but
I mean you tell me there's a character
named shades I'm like that's gonna be a
nonentity I really liked him so there's
a lot of good characters being put in
here there's a lot of good interactions
there's a lot of good performances but
as a whole it still didn't come together
for me and if I sort of set aside the
issue of I can't quite connect because
it's not my experience and it's not it's
just not a genre type lens working that
is normally what I gravitate towards
even if I set that aside
basic issues that I kind of have a
problem with for the vast majority of
the show it never really felt like Luke
Cage was up against much it felt like
the main thing holding him back was he
himself and when I say that I mean
basically until we get to the very end
and we get some of the more jacked up
tech that can actually take him down but
the first half almost two thirds of the
series it never feels like he's being
right I mean yes it's established of
people around him can get hurt the
community can be injured by what's going
on even though he's bulletproof but it
feels like the only reason that that the
series isn't only for so long is because
he has decided he's not going to kill
these people and that's fine as far as
it goes but I feel like we didn't get a
proper justification for why he won't
take that step I needed something I
needed just a line a speech I I think I
needed this speed I needed a full
justification for why he was not
prepared to just kill him because if
he's just gone in and killed cotton
mouth and said anyone else who tries to
fill the vacuum II left he's gonna
answer to me show would have been over
and that would have been in and the fact
that you know it strings out because
he's not willing to do that that's fine
but you need to explain to me why he's
not and I never I mean I get that he's
not a killer by nature but like it would
have solved things so easily I needed
something I needed Anna knowledge meant
that he is accepting there will be
damaged by the fact that he won't kill
these people and I need to understand
his justification as to why and I feel
like I never got that the other thing
with the villains is we get a villains
shift about halfway through and we get
the elimination of cottonmouth and I do
want to sing about sort of that whole
thing that was amazing because they took
something with what he said because the
orz has established him and Mariah their
club their cousins they grew up together
they are close but he says something to
her that is something that is so common
not just in entertainment but in reality
to be said when a woman
the abuse up on a woman has brought up
and he says you wanted it and when she
just flips on him and I don't mean just
like she gets angry and shoots and goes
oh my god what'd I do she hits him with
a bottle pushes him out of window goes
down the stairs and smashes his face in
with a mic stand the whole time
screaming I didn't want it
Wow that was good that was intense that
was a great transition point for her the
problem is they tried to fill the vacuum
left by cottonmouth with Diamondback and
Diamondback he never really worked from
well no I won't say never when he first
showed up and he's pulling lines from
the Warriors that was actually a very
cool introduction to the character but
then like the more we learn about him
and you know he's he grew up with Luke
Cage and he's out for a revenge because
he's been jealous since they were kids
and he's actually his brother and I
don't care I mean it would have worked
much better if there have been more
references to him and then I don't and I
don't mean the name drops of Diamondback
because those were all in the first half
I mean like if Luke had made some
mention of you know this his friend
growing up that boy I wonder what ever
happened to him or I had this new friend
and we were so close but then this thing
happens like somebody I could connect it
with instead this guy just shows up out
of nowhere and goes yeah you remember me
I'm your brother and I'm like and so I
was I was put off foot and like
immediately when he showed up and I
could never quite get on board with him
since then and that outfit they put him
in for the climactic fight not a good
outfit and actually the action scenes in
general aren't that spectacular which is
kind of a disappointment you would fix I
mean the assault oh you know when he
takes out that whole that whole facility
that was good but that's really that's
the action to highlight the rest of the
fights and this thing are kind of the
whole and I think by and large most of
my issues center around the villains in
some way the first half I have a problem
with the fact that the villains never
really
feel like there are proper threat to
Luke Cage and yet he won't take them out
and then the second half me a
diamondback who does feel like a proper
threat but doesn't feel properly
justified as a villain in terms of what
he's doing because I always have issue
with the whole disc agree that happens
when you have a character who has
obviously had to be patience and the
skill or whatever to work his way up
high into the ranks of organized crime
and never be caught and have discretion
to suddenly just be having fights out in
the open and killing his partners and
doing all this because he's got revenge
in his sights but I'm like help me keep
that under wraps for however many years
he had you to work his way up just to
blow it all on revenge I'm not gonna say
I can't buy that somebody could be that
petty but there's a disconnect there
between somebody who's able to rise that
high in the ranks and someone who will
jeopardize all of that just for a little
bit of revenge you wanted and that's not
unique to this Spectre basically did the
same thing with Blofeld and it didn't
work there either so it's weird to me
that most matches with the series center
around the villains because
villains have been the one area up until
this point that the Netflix shows have
really outshined the movies Fisk was
amazing killgrave was fantastic
and I don't want to sound like the
villains are complete washout yet I
really like Mariah Diller I'm glad she's
still around by the end of this I like
Scott malphur when he stuck around
diamond bag really didn't work for me
though and even though I liked Kon mouth
as a performance he still wasn't
completely working as a villain and I
think you know aside from that thing
that I talked about before just not
completely connecting with the vibe of
the thing and again I don't blame the
show for that I'd chalk that up to just
okay cultural difference it's not my
life it's not my world it's going for a
style of entertainment that isn't
normally what I grab taste for and
that's fine but between those two things
it was it was good I probably won't
rewatch it but those are my thoughts on
Luke Cage I'm definitely looking forward
to seeing Luke himself again come back
and the defenders so I'm not tired of
this guy but I I don't know how excited
I'll be for a second season of this
particular show but you know what we'll
see in any case have you seen the
entirety of Luke Cage yet and if you
haven't what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter High
Council geeks
check out the council geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned